come on
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor John
Ross Hello friends Pastor Doug is out
this evening but how about an amazing
fact
though close allies during the
tumultuous period of the American
Revolution Thomas Jefferson and John
Adams found themselves on opposite sides
of the political Spectrum in the later
years of their lives however despite
their differences a sense of mutual
respect and admiration into it the
philosophical differences did not
overshadow their shared commitment to
the principles that it ignited the birth
of the United States Civil and religious
freedom
in Atlanta twist of fate their lives
became further interwind as they
approached their final moments on the
4th of July in 1826 Thomas Jefferson
took his last breath at Monticello his
beloved home in Virginia
remarkably just hours later John Adams
passed away at his residence in Quincy
Massachusetts
this extraordinary coincidence was
heightened by the fact that that marked
the 50th anniversary of the adoption of
the Declaration of Independence a
document both men had worked on and
which carried their signatures
the alignment of their deaths with this
historic Milestone stands as a profound
reminder of the enduring principles that
they championed and which lay at the
core of the nation's Foundation civil
and religious liberty
you know friends the Bible tells us that
the United States was to rise up and
that it would be founded on two
christ-like principles we find in
Revelation chapter 13 a description of a
beast power that comes up from the earth
it has two horns like a lamb but it
speaks like a dragon it speaks like a
dragon let me read those verses you find
that in Revelation chapter 13 and
beginning verse 11.
then I saw another Beast coming up from
the Earth
and he had two horns like a lamb but his
fake as a dragon
and he exercised all the authority of
the first beast in his presence and
caused the Earth and those who dwell in
it to worship the first Beast whose
deadly wound was healed and he performed
Great Signs so that he even makes Fire
come down from heaven on the earth in
the sight of men
now if we allow the Bible to interpret
itself and you look at the various clues
in the very passage this power
represented is coming up from the earth
is none other than the United States of
America it came just in time
and even though it was founded on the
principles of civil and religious
freedom according to the verse there is
going to be a change that occurs in this
nation you know Pastor Cruz amazing
facts has a magazine that I think
everyone needs to read it's called
America in Prophecy and this is our free
gift to anyone who is watching or
listening we'll be happy to send it to
you all you need to do is call the
number is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for that
free gift it's America in Prophecy we'll
send it to you it's one of our most
popular magazines I read it and share it
to somebody else again that number is
800-835-6747 and if you have a Bible
question this is a live program this
evening the number to call is
800-463-7297 again that's
800-463-7297 my name is John Ross and
working the phones for US is Pastor
Aaron Cruz not a stranger to Bible
answers live you've helped out before
you are our young adult pastor at the
Granite Bay Hilltop church so thank you
for joining us here amazing great to be
here now of course before we go to the
phone lines we always want to begin with
prayer because we're recognize the Bible
is God's book so why don't you open with
the word of prayer all right let's pray
dear heavenly father Lord as we spend
this next hour answering questions from
your word we ask that your holy spirit
guide us as we direct people to what
your scripture says and what it means
for us today so we ask for you to guide
us in Jesus name amen amen
we are ready to go to the phone lines
who's our first caller for this evening
all right let's get going our first
caller today is junith calling in from
Nevada
hello Judith welcome to the show what's
your Bible question hello yes it's a
blessed evening to you both my question
is what program happened to the destiny
of Adam and Eve and the Devils when Adam
and Eve were not deceived by the dealer
all right well good question what would
have happened if Adam and Eve did not
fall prey to the devil's deceptions well
of course the Bible doesn't tell and now
we do know that God created a perfect
world and Adam and Eve they were
complete and perfect and God had a
beautiful garden which was their home
and had they remained loyal or faithful
to God they would have fulfilled his
purpose God said be fruitful and
multiply and replenish the earth the
earth would have been populated with
human beings living Immortal eating from
the Tree of Life and worshiping and
praising God and having an opportunity
to communicate with the angels how
different this world would be had Adam
and Eve remain faithful what would have
happened to the devil if Adam and Eve
remained loyal well the Bible doesn't
say I mean I think there was a
probationary time given even to the
devil for him to try and prove his case
and Adam and Eve not Fallen oh I don't
know maybe the end of the devil would
have come sooner but in giving into the
devil's Temptation the devil claimed the
Earth Is His sort of got a foothold you
might say in the universe and we see the
great controversy between Christ and
Satan good and evil playing out in our
world and of course that's even playing
out in our hearts and lives that's right
well while the Bible isn't crystal clear
on what would have happened to the devil
if Adam and Eve didn't sin we do know
that if Adam and Eve didn't sin it says
in Genesis 3 verse 22 that because they
sinned they were had to exit the garden
and they could no longer have access to
the tree of life right but at the end of
the book of the Bible we have Revelation
and at the end it says all those who do
his Commandments that are washed white
in his robes get to have access again to
the tree of life right so so we can
guess and speculate about what would
have happened or could have happened but
we know today what will happen to those
who are faithful to Jesus and accept his
sacrifice that we will get access again
to the Tree of Life at the second coming
amen so the Bible begins with the story
in a garden and it ends in a garden both
containing the Tree of Life
who's our next caller all right our next
caller is John calling in from Nebraska
hello John welcome to the program what's
your Bible question good evening
gentlemen thanks for taking my call uh
my question is on the uh seven last
plagues that I told a girl chapter 17
but it's chapter 16 of Revelation and uh
my question is
um are the seven last plagues going to
be in order as they are listed in the
Bible here I have the King James version
yeah we believe that they will be listed
in order as given now they probably will
be overlap and all of the plagues will
not take place universally immediately I
mean if you look at them the first one
is a terrible sword that comes upon
those who have the mark of the beast
that'll probably begin in different
places around the world and then the
second plague is the sea turns to blood
uh this couldn't happen Universal
immediately otherwise you know you would
have people running out of water very
quickly because the third place says
water turns to blood so it begins in one
place and then sort of spreads around
the globe the terrible Souls of breaking
out on the different people and then the
fourth plague talks about an intense
heat so yes we believe that these
plagues are sequential as given here in
scripture the final plague brings you
right up to the second coming of Christ
and judgment that comes upon those are
the mark of the beast those who have
Ward against God and against these
people now there is something
interesting to add to this at the end of
time there's going to be everyone's
going to be divided up into two groups
those who have them mark of the beast
according to Revelation 13 they are the
ones who suffer under the place then you
have those who have the Seal of God in
Revelation chapter 17 they're the ones
who protect it God protects them during
this terrible time so for the believer
we need not fear for if we are trusting
in Jesus will be sealed and will be
protected when these seven last plagues
get pulled out some theologians feel
that it could probably take place within
the period of about a year the Bible
says a plague shall come in one day one
prophetic days you go to one literal
year so just a lot of interesting things
you know we do have a study guide
that talks about the second coming of
Christ and the one thousand years known
as the Millennium that happens right
after Jesus comes and it's called a
thousand years of peace and we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who wants
to learn more about what the Bible says
about the second coming of Christ and
what happens right after Jesus comes
just call and ask the number is
800-835-6747 and ask for the study guide
It's called a thousand years of Peace
thank you for your call John who do we
have next all right next we have Gary
calling in from Illinois uh Gary hi
welcome to the program what's your Bible
question for us
thank you in Revelation Jesus critiques
seven churches only the Church of Smyrna
and Philadelphia he doesn't criticize
are there any churches in the present
day that are representative of these two
churches
okay well good question well of course
the seven churches you find in
Revelation chapter two and three in a
prophetic sense represents seven phases
of the Christian Church beating with the
church of Ephesus and then you have the
Church of smirn and it goes all the way
down to the Church of laodicea which is
really a description of the church today
it's in a spiritual lukewarm condition
and there is a call for Revival a
special laodicea and message you might
say but in addition to these broad
categories of seven phases of the
Christian Church uh it is true that
different churches might exhibit
different characteristics in other words
you can have a church in a particular
area that is suffering severe
persecution and they might be very
similar as described to the Church of
Smyrna Churchill in a time of terrible
persecution Jesus didn't give any word
of rebuke he just encouraged them to be
faithful and the Church of Philadelphia
was also a church that went through some
persecution but they really wanted to
find the truth they were committed to
the truth and proclaiming the soon
coming of Jesus and there's no word of
rebuke given to the Church of
Philadelphia so yes they refer to seven
time periods of Christian history but
different churches can fall into these
different categories as well yeah and
over beyond that which is a great answer
we have over and over in each one of the
churches it says this phrase he who has
an ear let him hear what the spirit says
to the churches right so just like
you're saying any church where I would
go a step further and say any individual
right if you have ears to hear to read
what the message of Jesus is to these
churches if these messages apply to you
well then we need to take it to heart
and listen to what the spirit is trying
to tell us through these ancient
messages that become ever so relevant
through the Holy Spirit today all right
very good well thank you for your call
Gary who do we have next all right next
we have someone who uh it's got a great
name I think Aaron calling in from New
York hello Aaron
um how you doing I'm doing fine Erin
yeah nice to hear you what question you
for us this evening several times when I
listened to SDA preachers and teachers
as they talk about the articles of
literature in the sanctuary I hear them
say that the altar of sacrifice is
before the labor
but recently I heard that they say that
the priest cleansed themselves at the
labor before they do their work at the
altar of sacrifice my question is which
one of those pieces of furniture is
actually first
okay good question well first of all
just from a geographical layout in the
sanctuary just for those who might not
be familiar with it the Old Testament
Sanctuary or the Tabernacles divided up
into three parts you have What's called
the courtyard and then you have the
first compartment called The Holy place
and then half the size of the first
compartment is the second compartment
known as the most holy or the holy of
holies so three divisions of the
sanctuary and all of this served as the
Shadow and a type of the ministry and
the Plan of Redemption Christ Ministry
and the Plan of Redemption so in the
courtyard you have the sacrifice that's
the altar of burnt sacrifice and then
you have a basin filled with water and
it's true the priests would have to wash
prior to him doing the service but
before he actually entered into the
sanctuary to sprinkle the blood from the
sacrifice on the altar of incense he
would also have to wash his hands and
his feet so there was a cleansing both
at the beginning of the service but also
prior to him entering into the holy
place there was also a work of cleansing
now all of these different articles of
furniture have spiritual significance of
course the ultra burnt sacrifice
symbolizes Calvary it's the death of
Jesus he is the Lamb of God that takes
Away The Sins Of The World the Laver
symbolizes baptism it is a washing a
renewal it is also a symbol of the death
burial and resurrection of Jesus because
just as a person is baptized they go
under the water and then they come up
out of the water Christ is baptized an
example for believers but it is a symbol
of death burial and Resurrection I mean
Jesus rose from the dead then he
ascended into the Heavenly Sanctuary
there to minister as our high priest so
the courtyard in the Earthly Tabernacle
represents the earth and the work that
Jesus does here on the earth the holy
Place work represents the work that
Jesus does or did when he arose and
ascended to Heaven he's our mediator he
is ministering on our behalf in heaven
but the Final Phase of this work as our
high priest occurs in the most holy
place and sometimes it's described as a
time of judgment you're reading Daniel
seven about a judgment that's set in
heaven in the Ancient of Days is there
and the books are open and Jesus comes
in before the Ancient of Days or the
father and there is a pre-advent or
pre-second coming judgment that takes
place and that's what's symbolized in
that most holy place of the sanctuary so
the Earthly was a shadow of the Heavenly
and it demonstrated God's Plan of
Redemption
all right thanks for your question Aaron
uh moving on to our next caller we have
Glenn calling in from Ohio welcome Glenn
to the program
hello I appreciate it and good evening
to you good evening uh when the Apostle
Paul came on the scene
he was going about arresting people that
were worshiping a false Messiah
until lo and behold he discovered on the
road to Damascus that that false Messiah
was the true Messiah and he started his
missionary journey
ended the letter J was not in the
English language until the 17th century
there was no such name as Jesus back
when Paul did his thing
what name did he preach under and if the
answer is Yeshua I would like to know
who it was that changed the name and why
yes uh Jesus is an English adaptation of
the Hebrew or the Aramaic Yeshua uh the
Aramaic name now the reason we use
English or the English pronunciation of
the name of Jesus is because we speak
English if you speak Spanish you will
pronounce the name of Jesus differently
or if you speak Hindi you'll pronounce
the name of Jesus differently so
depending upon what language you are
speaking there is a name specifically
given for Jesus and it's it's adapted I
should say from that that original
Hebrew word with variations now it's
important for us to understand who we're
talking about we need to know who Jesus
is of course Jesus knows all of the
languages of the world he knows when a
person is sincerely calling out to him
in prayer whether they use the name in
English or in Hebrew or Aramaic or if
they use the Spanish name of Jesus Jesus
knows that there referring to him and I
think that's the most important remember
Jesus not only has the name Jesus but
he's also referred to under different
names or titles in the Bible he is
referred to as the word Jesus referred
to as the living bread as the way the
truth and the life so these different
different words that describe aspects of
who Jesus is but we use the name Jesus
just because it's the English version of
his name yeah and I mean when Paul was
going around if he was speaking to the
Greeks he would he would say Jesus right
in the Greek if he was speaking to the
Hebrews he would you know he would say
that name in Hebrew Yeshua right
um and I don't know if he knew any more
languages but I'm sure he would try his
best to transliterate into other
different languages all right thank you
all right our next caller is James
calling in from the great state of Texas
James welcome to the program what's your
question
is for Hebrews chapter 11 verse 3.
did God create
other life on different planets other
than ours okay yes let me let me read
the verse for those who are listening
maybe they're driving in the car Hebrews
11 3 says by faith we understand that
the worlds were framed by the word of
God so the things which are seen were
not made with things that were visible
you your question was does God have
other intelligent beings on other other
worlds
yes sir because when we spoke when he
speaks of this world he says the world
but he's but he's saying worlds plural
other than more than one yes now this is
one verse but there are others that have
a reference to the idea of other
intelligent beings other than angels
that are out there in the universe we
don't know how many worlds there are I
mean inhabited planets but from
scripture we understand that our planet
Earth is the only one that fell prey to
the devil's deceptions the devil is able
to deceive a third of the Angels they
joined his Rebellion read about that in
Revelation 12. but as in reference
anything about the other created beings
joining Satan's Rebellion so it's just a
third of the angels to join him and then
of course the inhabitants of Earth are
deceived by the devil so they are these
these unfallen worlds as mentioned here
in Hebrews and some have wondered that
the 24 Elders that you read about in
Revelation chapter four and five if they
might be the representatives of groups
of unfallen Worlds now the Bible isn't
getting to the exact specifics but
there's hints to that I'm also thinking
of the passage in job where it says at
the time of the creation it says the
Stars sang For Joy and job speaks about
a day when the sons of God came to
present themselves before him and the
devil came representing Earth so from
these different passages of scripture
yeah we believe there are unfallen
worlds yeah um Paul talks about that
we're a spectacle to men into angels and
and he in Ephesians he talks about how
we manifest through the church the
wisdom of God is manifested to the
heavens right so there's these little
glimmers as John was sharing um that
yeah there seemed to be other unfallen
worlds that are certainly not coming in
and you know sneaking and visiting us
physically but they're they're looking
on to see the grace of God working in
the life of those who are following
Jesus that's right it seems that our
world is quarantined because of sin the
only ones that have access to the world
is the angels and then of course God
himself uh the unfolden rules they can
witness what's happening but they don't
interact yeah with us good question
thank you James all right our next
caller is calling in from New Jersey and
it's Peter hello
question is uh based on Genesis 1 I
think it's verse 9. is it more ideal to
have a vegetarian food diet than a meat
uh I I went to a vegetarian diet I feel
much better health-wise and uh
uh I wanted to ask you because if you
guys are vegetarians would you share
some foods that you guys could that we
could eat you know maybe like French
toast or pizza bagels or egg and cheese
omelets maybe you can share your wisdom
on it thank you yeah without getting too
specific about uh you know different
recipes but I think from a Biblical
perspective uh it's pretty clear that
the original diet that God gave in the
beginning was fruits and nuts and
vegetables well grains fruits and Grains
and nuts and vegetables were added after
the fall but that is the ideal diet you
know the medical world will tell you
that on uh what the vegetarian diet your
body functions the best it it's built
for that and you can also just see in
the um in the world of Athletics a
number of Endurance Sports Runners and
swimmers and cyclists many of them are
going believe it or not to a vegetarian
diet
even vegan yeah finding that that
actually provides more energy and it's
more sustained energy by eating a
plant-based diet diet so yes it's there
in the Bible I'm a big advocate of
eating a plant-based vegetarian diet I
am a vegetarian myself I'm born and
raised a vegetarian actually and never
really eat meat and I know you Aaron are
probably a vegetarian too yeah I'm
vegetarian as well raised as one and uh
yeah you mentioned a few vegetarian
foods of which were Pizza bagels and
such well those are vegetarian it's also
important to have an essential part of a
vegetarian diet vegetables and fruit I
know growing up as a vegetarian and you
know being in a community where I have
many vegetarian friends it's it's quite
amazing how vegetarians like to eat
anything but vegetables sometimes right
so we need to be balanced you know
holistic in our diet getting the grains
and the fruits and the vegetables
um to yeah be properly yeah with
nutrition and a matter of fact try it
you know if you're wondering well what
is a vegetarian diet good for me well we
know it is and if you're wondering try a
test it and see just go for set aside
three weeks and say I'm not gonna eat
any flesh foods for three weeks I'm
going to increase my salad content and
I'm gonna eat more vegetables and beans
and plant-based foods and see how you
feel just give yourself a three week
test and I tell you you'll feel
different you'll feel better
all right thank you for your call you
know we do have a study guide just
thought of it it's called God's free
health plan it's one of the amazing
facts study guides and it talks about
the biblical plan for health and we'll
be happy to send this to anyone who
calls and asks the number is simply
800-835-6747 that is our resource phone
line just ask for God's free health plan
and we'll be happy to send it to anyone
who calls and asks who do we have next
all right next we have uh Rebecca
calling in from Michigan where I used to
Pastor for about seven years so Rebecca
welcome to the program
thank you for calling
what's your question for us Rebecca
questions
look for verse 13.
I understand the basic concept what Paul
is teaching
I could do all things through Christ
which strengthen me I need a more
broader understanding what he was
meaning
okay well first of all I think he means
what he says right there if God asks us
to do something even though from our
human perspective we might think wow
this is this is impossible from our
perspective Paul is reminding us that in
Christ through Christ trusting in Christ
all things are possible and that's an
important lesson if God asks us to do
something he will give you the power to
do it I think of the story of Peter
the disciples are in the boat and there
was a terrible storm and they looked out
and they saw the form of somebody
walking on the water and they thought at
first it was some sort of a ghost but it
was actually Jesus and when they
realized that it was Jesus walking on
the Water Peter said Lord if it is you
call me bid me to come to you and Jesus
said come and Peter got out of the boat
and he walked on the water as long as he
kept his eyes fixed Upon Jesus Peter did
that which humanly is impossible to do
but then you read further in the story
when he took his eyes off Jesus well
what happened he began to sink and he
cried out and said Lord save me and I
think there's a lesson in that for us if
we keep our eyes fixed Upon Jesus and
when we say keeping our eyes fixed Upon
Jesus means keep your thoughts centered
on Christ and his word if we are
centering our thoughts and our lives on
Jesus and his teachings the Holy Spirit
enables us to do something which we
cannot do in and of ourself you can take
the words of Paul and claim them I can
do all things through Christ that
strengthens me and of course it's in the
context of doing the things that God
asks us to do that's right this is not a
promise for us to say well you know I'm
going to become a millionaire because I
can do all things through Christ and
strength that might not be God's will
for your life but if God has asked you
to do something you can trust that he's
going to give you the strength to do it
yeah and in the specific context if you
read the two verses before he says
whatever state I am in to be content I
know how to be a beast I know how to
abound everywhere and in all things I've
learned to be full and be hungry to
abound and to suffer need right so that
means if you're in a condition where
you're in a really difficult time in
your life right you can make it through
through Christ right any situation that
you're going through of difficulty in
particular
Christ can give you strength to get
through that you know we have a book
that I think we don't always offer it
but it's a great read and it's just
packed with scripture it's called tips
for resisting temptation we live in a
world of sin we have carnal human
natures and if you're going to be honest
with yourself if you want to live the
Christian Life you're going to find a
struggle taking place the devil doesn't
want to let you go and sin is always
present but we can't overcome we can
resist we can't be victorious if we
follow the example given to us by Jesus
by claiming the promises of the Bible
and looking to him we'll send that book
for free to anyone who calls and asks us
called tips for existing Temptation I
think every Christian needs to read this
book if you want to know what the Bible
the Bible keys and and and
promises for victory in living the
Christian Life the number to call for
that is
800-835-6747 again you can ask for the
book written by Pastor Doug it's called
tips for existing Temptation we'll be
happy to send that to you if you're in
North America in Canada now if you're
outside of North America and you want to
read the book just go to our website
just
amazingfacts.org you can read the book
for free it's there online at the Free
Library we're just going to take a short
break and we'll be back friends with
more Bible questions in just a moment
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
did you know that Noah was present at
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating Zoo from the creation of the
world to the last day of events of
Revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore major Bible events
and characters enhance your knowledge of
the Bible and draw closer to God's word
go deeper visit the amazing Bible
timeline at biblehistory.com
within the pages of the Bible
great Heroes
Heroes of great Deeds
great love
and great sacrifice
but behind them is an
isn't hidden in plain sight amid the
Shadows
he was there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
over the golden thread of a savior woven
throughout the entire Bible tapestry
Shadows of light
seeing Jesus in all the Bible a new book
by Doug Batchelor
get your copy today by calling
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
once again to purchase your copy of
Shadows of light call
800-538-7275
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7 pm
and 8pm Pacific time to receive any of
the Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now let's read join our
hosts for more Bible answers live
Hello friends and welcome back to Bible
answers live if you're just joining us
this is a live interactive International
Bible study and if you have a Bible
related question we'd love to hear from
you this evening the number to call for
that is
800-463-7297 that's 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now we're going to give you
another number it's the free offer we're
going to give you some additional study
material and to get that it's just
800-835-6747 that is our resource phone
line and if you'd like to receive any of
the free information that we share with
you you want to call and ask for that
you know pastor we want to kind of greet
some of our friends who are tuning in we
have folks listening not only on
land-based radio stations but on
satellite we also have people watching
on the internet on various television
networks so who do we want to greet this
evening yeah all over the place but
specifically those who are tuning in on
k-a-s-k uh in Vacaville California
that's not actually too far down the
road here and from k-a-r-m uh tuning in
on Visalia here in California as well so
just a shout out to those who are
listening on those broadcasts all right
again if you have a Bible question the
number is
800-463-7297 we're gonna go straight to
the phone lines who do we have next all
right we've got Henry calling in from
New York welcome Henry uh
my question is
um
is it written ending in the Bible
anybody who who is alive today can they
prove that they were a thunder of stone
or David
okay does the Bible say anywhere that uh
somebody can trace back the ancestry to
David or Solomon well not directly
however it's important for us to realize
that David and Solomon came from the
tribe of Judah and the tribe of Judah
was one of the tribes that stayed in the
vicinity of Jerusalem in the area where
Jerusalem is the Ten tribes of Israel
were conquered the northern kingdom was
conquered by the Assyrians they were
dispersed amongst the various other
nations that's where the Samaritans come
from they intermarried with some of the
other nations there however the tribe of
Judah and Benjamin which was a smaller
tribe and most of Levi they stayed in
the area of the Southern Kingdom Judah
was a very big tribe and when Jerusalem
was conquered in 605 BC by
Nebuchadnezzar the Jews went into
captivity for seven years but many of
them returned back to Jerusalem they
rebuilt the temple and that's where Jew
comes from the name Jew comes from the
tribe of Judah so they are Jews today
that perhaps can trace the ancestry to
the tribe of Judah maybe they can even
trace it back further the Bible's not
clear there's no genealogy specifically
but it does lead us down to the time of
Christ there were Jews from the tribe of
Judah at that time
all right well hey thanks so much for
calling in Henry our next caller is Mark
calling in from Oregon welcome Mark
what's your question good evening
my prophecies in the Bible after 1844
which I do believe how do we reconcile
this to someone who says
the Bible predicts Israel's return as a
nation in 1948. okay good what's the
right answer yeah good question when it
comes to a specific time prophecy you
are correct the longest time prophecy
that we have in the Bible is Daniel 8 14
under 2 300 days then the sanctuary
shall be claims we know from Daniel
chapter 9 that the starting point for
that time prophecy was the decree to
restore and rebuild Jerusalem which went
into effect the first was by Cyrus but
it was really the third decree by artist
Xerxes which allowed the Jews not only
to rebuild the Temple but really the
city and create their own form of
government that marked the beginning
time period of the 2 300 days 457 BC was
that date he had 2 300 to 457
recognizing there's no year zero when
you go from BC to 80 you end on the date
1844. we know that to be the longest
time prophecy however there are still
other prophecies that we have in
Scripture that might not have a specific
date attached to it and I don't believe
that 1940 V8 even though that might be
very well the date when Israel the
Modern Nation of Israel was formed as a
government that specific date is not
referenced in Scripture there are the
historical incidents that occur that
might not have a specific date connected
with it certain events that even take
place in the future that don't have a
specific date I'm thinking for one that
would be the close of human probation
before the seven last plagues are poured
out the enforcement of the mark of the
beast these are things that are going to
happen in the future but there's no
specific date that you can point to the
last date based on Prophecy 1844 yeah
the after the time of Jesus and once the
Jewish Nation corporately as a as a
group of of people rejected Jesus as
their Messiah the Israel that we find in
Bible prophecy really refers to all of
God's faithful people right whether
whatever your ethnic Heritage may be the
true Israel of God are those who follow
Jesus and just a verse for that real
quick is Galatians 3 verse 29 it says if
you are Christ then you are Abraham's
seed and heirs according to the promise
so whatever happened in 1948 where
Israel as a ethnic people group as a
political Nation got restored back to to
you know that that land there that's
that that's a nice thing to happen for
them as a nation however that doesn't
seem to be any kind of a fulfillment in
Bible prophecy especially another time
period right not the time as we see
there in scripture all right thank you
thanks for your call Mark all right our
next caller is Cindy calling in from
California welcome to the show Cindy
thank you good evening Pastor Ross and
Pastor Cruz
um thank you for taking my call tonight
I was wondering could you explain God
hardening Pharaoh's heart between each
plague before The Exodus okay good
question
um before I answer this era maybe you
can look up the verse where it says
Pharaoh hardened his own heart as well
so this the verse speaks about God
hardening for his heart but then there's
also a verse that talks about uh Pharaoh
hardening his heart so there's a part
that God played in the hardening of
pharah's heart and that was bringing the
plagues upon Egypt how Pharaoh responded
to the plagues was his own personal
choice
so in one sense God hardened pharah's
Heart by bringing him to a point of
testing and how he responded to the
testing well that was up to Pharaoh
somebody's once explained it this way
um they think of the sun and the sun
shines with the same heat and if you
have wax and you have Clay the Sun the
heat of the sun will harden the clay but
it will melt the wax it's the same sun
and so likewise as the plagues fell upon
Egypt there was those who whose Hearts
was melted they recognized that they
were Sinners but there were those who
hardened their heart like pharaoh and
most of the Egyptians however there were
some Egyptians that actually came up out
of Egypt with the Israelites so there
were some that their hearts were humbled
through that experience yeah the sun can
shine upon wax and it melts right and
the sun shines upon clay and it hardens
right in Exodus 8 verse 15 this is the
first time it references Pharaoh's heart
being hardened and it says that when
Pharaoh saw that there was relief he
that is Pharaoh hardened his heart and
did not heed them as the Lord had said
before it ever says that the Lord
hardened Pharaoh's heart it actually
says multiple times that Pharaoh
hardened his own heart right in response
to those plagues exactly you know
sometimes in the Bible God God is um but
God is recognized as the one doing
something even though he might bring a
person to appointed decision the
ultimate decision is up to the person
but God will bring them to that that
situation and that's what was happening
here with Pharaoh yeah that's right
great question Cindy thanks for calling
our next caller is Howard calling in
from Oklahoma welcome Howard to the show
thank you I was pondering Revelation 12
verse 7 where it says there was war in
heaven Michael and his angels sought to
dragon in the dragonfly was that like a
literal War where angels are killing
each other and everything or is that
more of a war on words
and ideals or whatever kind of like the
Republicans and Democrats are battling
it out you know can you in light on
that because sure absolutely I'll see
you later on in job you know after this
after he gets get out of Heaven Satan
just pops in there like hey fellas you
know I just come from Earth you know
right representative yeah all right well
first of all there's definitely a battle
of ideas and the devil's making
accusations against God uh for one he's
saying that God isn't really fair we
don't need his law
uh maybe even said that God is not a god
of love because he expects us to be
obedient to his commandments so there
was there was a clash of ideas a clash
of thoughts uh there was open discussion
without a doubt because the third of the
Angels joined Satan in his Rebellion so
there was a lot of Tate talking taking
place but at some point when this
Rebellion really broke out speaking of
Lucifer in the Old Testament it says
that he wanted to take God's Throne so
that was his final goal he wanted to be
like the most high and I think at some
point the devil and these Angels were
driven outside of Heaven I don't think
they're left willingly they were
actually pushed out I don't think any of
the Angels lost their lives we don't
know what type of battle was involved
I'm sure they didn't use weapons of some
kind but they were physically removed
from heaven and then they kind of went
through the universe looking for another
place that they could call home and
right around that same time the Earth is
being created and the devil says Ah
here's my chance let me try and tame the
Adam and Eve so that is the battle that
you read about in Revelation chapter 12.
yeah and and how we can know that it's
really more so a battle like you were
kind of mentioning over sort of like the
Republicans and the Democrats an idea
over a battle over ideas and how to run
the universe is the name the titles
given to the dragon it says in
Revelation 12 that in verse 9 that the
Great Dragon is called the devil and
Satan who deceives the whole world right
and so here the word devil actually
means uh one who Slanders right so in
the very name of Satan devil is slander
that's gossip right and then it echoes
back to the serpent of old that's
Genesis 3 and in Genesis 3 we don't see
Satan you know suffocating wrapping his
tail around Eve but rather he's he's
he's he's he's he's selling her on a new
version of God God is lying to you you
can't trust him right so he's attacking
the very character of God and and making
us believe that we shouldn't obey his
commands Clash of ideas oh although you
know there was the Bible says he was
cast to the Earth so there was something
involved there you know we do have a
study guide It's called did God create a
devil yeah and we happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks you might be
wondering if God is a god of love why
did it allow the devil to be in
existence well call and ask the number
is
800-835-6747 ask for the study guide
It's called did God created devil we'll
be happy to send it to you here in the
U.S or in Canada if you're outside of
North America just go to our website
just amazingfacts.org who do we have
next all right next we have uh Robert
calling in from California hi there
Robert how you doing
oh great how are you thank you great
my question uh it's about the 144 000 in
Revelation I just want to kind of
clarification at the very very very end
they are basically the purest of the
pure that has survived everything and as
as I understand it at the very end when
Jesus comes will there be people saved
or Alive other than the 144 000 that
will go to heaven okay good question
well let me just give for those who are
listening a little bit of background of
144 000 you read this in Revelation
chapter seven and leading up to that the
last verse of Revelation chapter 6
describes the second coming of Christ
and it answered the question it says the
great day of his wrath has come and who
shall be able to stand so the question
is asked who's going to be able to stand
when Jesus comes and then Revelation
chapter 7 describes a group of people
who have the Seal of God in their
foreheads and we understand that the
Seal of God has to do with the anointing
of the Holy Spirit it is a reflection of
his character in a particular manifest
in obedience to his Commandments because
Revelation 12 17 says here are those who
keep the Commandments of God and they
have the testimony of Jesus so
um obedience in the last days motivated
by love becomes a critical part of the
seal so at the end of time you only have
two groups of people those are the mark
of the beast and those with the Seal of
God now the 144 000 they serve as God's
end time Apostles you might say you have
12 Apostles that helped launch the early
Christian Church here you have 12 times
12 times a thousand 144 000 representing
a large group of people who are taking
the Three Angels messages to the world
and as a result of their preaching and
sharing the Everlasting gospel there are
more than 144 000 literal people that
are sealed and standing when Jesus comes
the second time Revelation goes on
Revelation 7 talks about a great
multitude from every nation Kindred
tongue and people that is standing uh
when Jesus comes that are resurrected
many of which are resurrected but those
are the Seal of God they're alive so uh
we can get too worried about the number
144 000 you know the tendency is for
people to start counting and they do the
math and they think wow if only 144 000
people are going to be alive and
translated to heaven when Jesus comes
what are my odds right but we've got to
recognize Revelation is a symbolic book
and if you read on in the chapter 12 000
from each of the tribes there is
spiritual significance even to the
numbers that we find in the Book of
Revelation uh we need not worry whether
or not there's going to be enough room
for us if we receive Jesus and surrender
to him we can have the promise of being
sealed and being amongst those who are
ready for Jesus when he comes amen
all right thank you next caller all
right our next caller is ginger calling
in from Texas and ginger she is a
first-time caller so hey welcome Ginger
to the program
Lord thank you very much and good
evening pastors
um I uh my question is
I have a
I believe it's the second commandment
love thy neighbor as thyself well I do
love my neighbors and I am a recent
Widow and and been blessed by my husband
and the Lord and these temporary
neighbors who are renting for my
neighbor are not so nice
um they
um help themselves to my property and to
whatever they want and um
I pray for them every night and I'd like
to know how I can
um
not fear and not be angry with them and
even as I said I pray every night for
them okay please help me yeah absolutely
Ginger well you know being a Christian
is not always easy and of course we meet
difficult people and we've got to pray
for grace how to work with them uh first
of all you know you can pray for them
you can be the best example
if they taken advantage of you uh
there's nothing wrong in you explaining
to them that this is not allowed to
happen and you know if you have to ask
them to move or have them moved if
they're renting from you or whatever the
case might be you can do so you don't
have to live in fear but despite that
you need to still pray for them which
you do and you need to love them the
Bible says that we can go to Jesus with
all of our cares we can cast all our
cares upon Him for he cares for us so
there there is a balance the one we
don't want to be taken advantage of and
there are laws in our land to help
protect us and there's nothing wrong in
seeking for help in order if there are
laws to protect you but at the same time
individually we don't want anger to eat
us up because the one who really is
harmed with anger is the one who is
angry at the other kind of eats us up
from the inside so that's where we pray
and say Lord give us a forgiving spirit
and let the spirit of Jesus guide you
and then just make wise choices maybe
speak with the with a Godly friend and
say you know what do you think would be
the right thing for me to do in this
situation yeah uh the verse that you
were quoting earlier about casting all
our cares upon Upon Jesus is First Peter
five or seven if you want to mark that
in your Bible and keep going back to it
and also I'd recommend reading Matthew
Chapter 5 and 6 where Jesus has some
words to say about what we should do uh
to our enemies right to pray for them
and he also talks about
um if we're fearful or anxious and what
we should do right and ultimately we are
to put first the kingdom of heaven cast
all our cares upon Him and he'll
continue to provide for us
all right thank you for your call Ginger
who do we have next all right next we
have uh Dana calling in from Nevada
hello welcome to the program
yes thank you for taking my question
which is when Jesus died on the cross he
was resurrected
um what happened to his mind
um he was half human half uh holy or or
Divine uh unlike us who when we die we
don't go to heaven uh or what are my
where did his mind go okay
um yeah what happened to Jesus when he
died well first of all he wasn't half
human and half Divine I mean I
understand what you're saying he was 100
human and he was 100 Divine however
Christ did not use his divinity when he
was on the earth he relied upon his
father just like we need to rely upon
our father that's why when the disciples
asked him and said you know when are you
coming back Jesus said the only one who
knows is my Father in heaven uh while
Jesus knows now obviously but that
hadn't been revealed to him by the
father and as Jesus grew as a child he
learned he learned the very things that
he had instructed Moses to write he grew
in knowledge and wisdom and so
um he laid aside his divinity when Jesus
came to the Earth he was divine but he
later decide he didn't use his divinity
for himself it was a blessing father so
when Christ died on the cross and he was
placed in the Tomb uh he he was not
conscious he was not aware of what was
happening that Divinity had been laid
aside and when he was resurrected and he
came to life then he was conscious of
what was happening around him so Jesus
was not away from his body when it was
in the Tomb and he was witnessing things
and still conscious of what was
happening he was dead and the reason we
know that is because the Bible the Bible
says the wages of sin is death and Jesus
Paid the penalty for our transgression
it was real death that Christ
experienced so there is a mystery we
don't understand how cry could be 100
divine 100 man there is an Act of Faith
in just accepting what the Bible says
some of these things will probably be
further explained when we get to heaven
but from the Bible it's pretty clear
that when Jesus died he was dead and he
rose again early Sunday morning yeah and
one thing I want to add is in John
chapter 20 and verse 17 after Jesus has
resurrected uh Mary is there right and
Mary is just so excited to see Jesus
that she clings to him she grabs hold of
him and Jesus responds to her and he
says do not cling to me for I have not
yet ascended to my father right so here
Jesus is making clear that hey while he
was in the Tomb he was not in heaven
whisked away to heaven right now or in
hell he was in the Tomb okay thank you
good question all right our next caller
is Giselle calling in from Massachusetts
welcome Giselle what's your Bible
question for us
hi yes my question is in Psalm 119
verse two it said blessed are those who
keep his testimonies but I don't know
what that means to keep his testimonies
okay good question now when you look at
the Bible it's the Old Testament and
then also the new but beginning with the
Old Testament the Old Testament is
really divided up into two parts
especially for the Hebrew mind for the
Jew the first part is what they refer to
as the law and the law was the first
five books written by Moses and then
there was what they called the prophets
also referred to as the testimonies and
that was the writings in the rest of the
Old Testament so you have the law and
the prophets that's what the Bible says
in the mouth of two or three Witnesses
every truth is to be established to the
law or to the testimony if they speak
not according to this there is no light
in them the Bible says so the
testimonies refers to the writings of
the prophets now the New Testament is
really an extension of the prophets so
you still have those two divisions you
have the law the first five books
written by Moses you have the Old
Testament writings of the prophets and
really the new estimate is an extension
of the writings of the prophets so we
still have those two witnesses or those
two testimonies so when David says
blessed are those who keep his
testimonies it's not only his law but
it's also those who hearken unto the
prophets the Bible says here His
prophets believe them and you shall
prosper so the testimonies in a broader
sense of what God has given his people
as revealed through the writings of the
prophets that's right yeah thank you so
much Giselle for the question you know
one more thing just to add to that uh
you know we find the same thing for
God's Remnant people in the last days
Revelation 12 17 talks about those who
keep the Commandments of God that's the
law and they have the testimony of Jesus
that is the spirit of Prophecy according
to Revelation 19 10. so they're also
obedient not only to the Ten
Commandments to the law but also to the
rest of scripture that which has been
revealed through the prophets through
the spirit of Prophecy good point good
point
all right on to our next question uh we
have Mo who is a first-time caller
calling in from our very own California
welcome Mo to the program
oh thanks for taking my call my question
is um
why are the most churches nowadays uh
still uh breaking uh God's uh rules
regulations and Commandments of
collecting Society because my
understanding is that um prizing was the
only the only one permitted to collect
tithing was the high priest out of the
tribal Levi and the only people that
were supposed to pay the tithing was the
11 tribes of Israel to the One Tribe of
Levi you know and that high priest that
was uh the only one allowed to collect
it had to go through a ritual ceremony
and had to be between the ages of I
think 24 and 55 and they had it yeah
Aaron yeah let me jump in MO we're going
to run out of time uh good question
though why do uh Christian churches
encourage folks to give tithe well if
you look at the New Testament example
tithe is actually really the beginning
of the giving the Bible speaks of the
Church of Acts where it says people sold
land and houses and they freely gave to
the work of the Proclamation of the
Gospel but in New Testament times if the
church is going to fulfill its mission
of taking the gospel to the world it
needs to have support from the members
and the tithe principle that we find in
the Old Testament is really just the
starting point in addition to ties we
also find offerings now it is true we
don't have a temple and we don't have a
high priest as the Jews did but we do
have a Heavenly Temple and our high
priest is Jesus and even though we can't
Ascend up to heaven and place it in his
hand when we give it to the furtherance
of his work we are giving it to Christ
and so yes we still return our tires to
the high priest Jesus but we do so by
supporting the work of the Proclamation
of the Gospel so we are in harmony with
what happened in the Old Testament with
a spiritual application which is a
little bit different you know we do have
a study guide that talks about this and
has a lot more scriptures it's called In
God We Trust we'll be happy to send it
to anyone who calls and asks again that
number is 800
835-6747 again just ask for that study
guide It's called In God We Trust we'll
send it to you if you're in the U.S or
in Canada if you're outside of North
America just visit our website now
friends you hear the music in the
background we're going to say goodbye to
those listening on satellite but for the
rest of you stand by we're going to come
back with some email Bible questions
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
all right welcome back we have two
minutes here to wrap up with some email
questions thank you all those who have
been emailing in questions you can email
questions into
balquestions at
amazingfacts.org so some of the
questions we have for today is violet
she emailed in and asked in reading the
Old Testament I noticed that Israel is
involved in many wars we preach that God
is love so I do not understand why these
wars were happening can you please
explain okay good question yes the Bible
does contain War but in addition to war
it is also contain acts of judgment for
example the ten plagues that Came Upon
Egypt you have the army of the Egyptians
destroyed in the Red Sea you've got the
flood that destroyed the wicked you've
got fire that came down on Sodom
Gomorrah so there are times where God
will act as judge in order to preserve
truth he might bring judgment upon some
Wicked Nation or city that is God doing
the work and in the case of Israel going
to war they were obeying a commandment
given specifically by God and God was
very specific on which nation they were
to attack and what they were to do so it
was an act of judgment however
individually the Bible tells us that we
need to trust ourselves to God and Jesus
said if somebody strikes you on the One
Cheek what do you do you turn the other
the Bible says vengeance is mine saith
the Lord we are to love our enemies so
on a personal application uh absolutely
we need to trust ourselves to God and
love and pray for those that persecute
us all right next question we have Zach
who asks Jesus told the thief on the
cross that he would be with Christ in
Paradise was the thief part of the
firstfruits when Christ resurrected okay
well good question well first of all
where the thief says to Christ
um you know Lord remember me it's
important to note the thief said Lord
remember me when you come in your
kingdom so the thief wasn't expected to
receive a reward that day Jesus gave him
the assurance that day you will be with
me in Paradise verily I say unto you
today you shall be with me so the
promise was that he would be remembered
when Jesus came the second time that's
when the thief was to receive his reward
now was he part of the special
Resurrection uh probably not because he
was asking that Christ would remember
him when he comes in his kingdom however
the Bible doesn't tell us who were the
ones part of that special resurrection
that occurred at the time of Christ's
Resurrection they were taken to heaven
and uh I guess we'll have to wait until
we get to heaven to find out who exactly
they were that's right well you know
friends I'm looking at the clock Pastor
Aaron I don't think we have time for
another question again we want to thank
you so much for emailing your questions
to us here at amazing facts we look
forward to studying further again next
week tell your friends and visit the
website amazingfacts.com till then God
bless
[Music]
live honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions
[Music]